[Music]
this is will Miller Firaxis games one of
the co-lead designers on sid meier's
civilization beyond Earth
beyond Earth is a new science-fiction
entry in the Civilization family of
games they lead a colony from Earth to
settle an alien world and write the next
chapter for Humanity the version we're
playing is an alpha version of the game
so you may see some placeholder artwork
or bugs or working to fix those by
launch as you can see we've settled on a
lush alien planet with deep rift canyons
full of magma and miasma which are
environmental hazards and an alien nest
nearby there's a Manticore which is an
alien that can make ranged attacks now
our Explorer isn't really intended to
fight aliens and by fighting the aliens
we may make them more aggressive towards
us so instead we'll investigate this
resource pod resource pods were sent
ahead of our colonists by the people of
Earth by investigating these we can get
resources from them let's send our
Explorer in to collect now we're ready
to see how our colony's Verret as we
move across the world you can see a
number of features here
this is Fort Miller a military station
if we set up a trade route with them
will receive a powerful cease unit for
our military and here we have a new
alien life-form the siege worm this can
destroy tile improvements just by
passing through them and they're very
hard to kill with just one military unit
we'll leave this guy alone for now
there are also a number of alien
artifacts on this world like this huge
alien skeleton let's end our exploring
take a closer look
once our Explorer finishes his work in a
few turns we'll gain a reward ranging
from scientific research to resources or
even an alien unit that's under our
control as we move towards our capital
you can see that our colony is thriving
on this new world
around our city here we have plantations
for fruit and tubers to feed our people
as well as a node improvement and even a
wonder the gene vault now we have some
quest decisions to make quests are a new
feature for beyond Earth and are a way
for players to create narrative within
the game in this case we've just
completed the quest gifts from home in
civilization games the story is always
created by the actions players take
these quests are there to provide some
additional context with meaningful
choices each quest decision results in a
gain of some kind for your faction now
we have another quest called for your
eyes only we've just built the spy
agency within our capital and we're
ready to send our covert agent into the
field in the American reclamation
corporation city of central now our
agent is on his way to central and once
he arrives he'll begin to generate
intrigue in that city as intrigue level
rises we can move from simple covert ops
like monitoring and smuggling to more
complex ones
like planting attractors to bring siege
worms toward the city covert ops will
play an important role in your
interaction with other factions on this
world now let's touch on affinities
which are a vision for how humanity's
future might evolve and how it changes
the world throughout the game there are
three types of affinities permanent
purity and supremacy our faction is
adopted supremacy which is the belief
that human beings need to be able to be
independent the worlds they settled
through technology augmentation and
cybernetics supremacy SIVs believe that
human beings will be able to settle any
world our devotion to supremacy is
reflected in a style of architecture in
our cities and the look of our military
units you gain devotion to an affinity
through many means objects and resource
pods that are an affinity they're
excavating ruins found on the planet and
even through the tech web which is the
main way you learn affinity because we
don't know how humanity's technology
will evolve we've created the tech web
for beyond
you start in the middle and then move
out through the web for progressively
more exotic technology there are branch
techs and leaf techs and you can see by
the affinity icons next to them which
leaf X will raise your devotion to that
affinity let's choose another supremacy
tech to research now let's talk to some
leaders who have made some different
affinity choices we see here that
fueling is wearing flowing garments with
laurel wreath adornments that called
back to earth's classical past she's
adopted the purity affinity purity
factions believe that this world needs
to be transformed into a new earth for
human beings as they are right now
fueling is on a different part of the
continent so she's less of a concern to
us than other leaders sure guru
samet our Shama Bari of the People's
African Union has greenish clothing and
those ports going into his head which
means his faction has adopted the
Harmony affinity harmony saves want to
transform humanity into something like a
native species on this new world through
genetic modification and gene-splicing
as a supremacy faction we find tying
yourself closely to one planet to be
tragically short-sighted as it happens
bar a also has settled cities near a
strategic resource that's critical to us
for exciting peroxide is used by
supremacy factions to build powerful
military units and buildings and bar a
has declined to trade for it we need
this for ourselves we've got a
liberation force assembled here you can
see the visual style of our affinity
reflected in their design but most
importantly they're reinforced by
tactical satellite this tactical
satellite is from our new settlement and
was launched to assist with the attack
as long as it's in orbit it will assist
our units with healing as well as combat
bonuses if Bari is to survive he should
destroy this as soon as possible as the
game progresses we can unlock many other
types of satellites as well not just
military ones there are others that can
be used to clear miasma increase
research and so forth let's begin our
attack
must you bring always to a new home
now that we've liberated barrei cities
the others will fall in due course and
we'll continue our march to victory
thanks for watching this demo sid
meier's civilization beyond Earth comes
out this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you